okay touch me bro all right boys the
last one this is brace from Virginia
Beach hell yeah I love people that are
named after things that like are also
like other things I was so boys I got a
quick King under sting it for you so my
parents they have a birthday in their
bathroom and I'm gonna be honest I've
tried it out I've tried it out party boy
I want to know y'all's opinions know
your comedians I'm sure you've been in
some nicer hotels and I mean you know
some people think it's a little
homoerotic to be using a bidet I like it
well you know you and your brother used
to play that game growing our last
episode just let me know what you think
but days can get her stinging dengue
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz young man listen I'm a
but Dave fan have you ever sat down one
of those new toilets that are out there
automatic dude i sat down oh when I was
in dr. blood they can tell your blood
pressure they can do whatever you want
get you a grilled cheese whatever you
want please sit down and you can put the
warm water like you done taking a Dookie
it'll sprays that warm water all over
your junk from the balls to the the
booty hole and it is so refreshing and
nice it's a bidet it's a new-age bidet
now have I drank from a bidet cuz I
thought was a water fountain
yeah half and it was in my uncle's house
haha and I did that for many years in
Venice California oh that's why I'm such
a large man fan of the New Age bidets if
you raised all day water yeah my dad
never told me you're gonna put on some
size dude okay second of all first team
all the day
look man uh what was the guy asking us
bday days yeah but days man hmm you
don't want to be walking around with em
dingleberries like all [ __ ] swamp ass
man that but they cleans it right the
French had it right dude clean your
[ __ ] I know some friends that clean
an [ __ ] in a sink usually can't
afford a bidet I don't think you need a
I mean I think if you're used to
cleaning your [ __ ] regularly like you
know most people are almost a hundred
percent of people probably a hundred
percent of people then I think you just
do that but if you're some [ __ ]
psychopath who has to have warm water
shot at their [ __ ] well it's not it's
not you you live have you ever had it
done oh I've been on one of these
suckers before man I don't like really
it feels like an invasion of privacy if
I miss a little a tool I get a little
turned on it's hot water it's almost
like aliens coming in like usually pass
and have an erection
[Laughter]
bidets man I just it just seemed like a
Dark Arts to me man the darkest yeah it
seems like but it's clean airy it just I
mean it's God's work man
I would rather kind of hold like lift
one of my legs up and kind of hold my
ass open a little bit in the shower like
an adult
it seems that's a bidet different style
though yeah but I'm top and sit it down
below I'd rather meet the devil halfway
dude then just sit right there on that
fire hose what do they say brother no
this is for you guys to say this is King
under sting Oh King it love them
if they're done right they're done right
right dude it's not a [ __ ] carrot
cake here's the thing bro I've got some
bidets they get gets messy that's how
much pressure the feather the [ __ ]
strings a little too fat yeah it gets
water up you know I'm feeling a little
too strong come a little too hot oh yeah
gotta be done right it's just so risky
when you could just clean your own but
it's so risk that water shot at your
[ __ ] and an unknown [ __ ] speed or
pressure when you could just easily
clean your own butt like you've been
doing for decades yeah I'm with you man
I'm a fan of the days
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]